greece and ukraine can the eu take the
strain
in the interview european commission
president jean-claude juncker
mr juncker the ukraine crisis is just
one of many a wave of migrants is
attempting to enter the eu the economic
crisis in greece the euroskeptic parties
ukip the national front and pagita here
in germany
it must be keeping you awake at night
no i can't really afford to have sleep
this night
you have to be wide awake to keep track
of all the challenges facing europe
so i make sure to sleep well
but i'm certainly concerned
there's fraying at the edges
and those fringe parties may soon move
to the center if we don't address the
issues appropriately
new questions arise and old ones raise
their heads again
namely whether europe truly can be a
stable home of peace and understanding
europe's desire for a peaceful order is
being challenged through russia's
actions in crimea and eastern ukraine
all of these things are cause for
concern
do you believe the eu can remain unified
in these troubled times that it can
withstand these forces
i have a feeling and that's all it is
right now that more and more citizens
realize that european nations must
continue to grow closer
to become more unified
our people only have to look to the eu's
periphery to see methods at work that
hark him back to the first half of the
20th century
policies are in play powers are seeking
to redraw borders
people see that europe is becoming
weaker from a demographic point of view
this is a dramatic problem
our share of global gdp is shrinking
substantially
our citizens fully realize that these
facts pose a challenge for each and
every individual country
for that reason there's an increasingly
broad consensus
that european unity is vital
of course some people haven't yet come
to this conclusion
we all know that common sense isn't
evenly distributed among nations and
their citizens
you met for the first time with new
greek prime minister alexis cyprus in
brussels last week the two of you shook
hands and didn't let go
you left the conference room hand in
hand why did you do that was it an
attempt to ease tensions
i'm well acquainted with the new prime
minister he was also a candidate for eu
commission president
now he's the greek prime minister and
i'm the commission president
so it was a cordial greeting there's no
reason for it to be otherwise we're not
in some kind of contentious conflict
with the greek people and their new
government we can be courteous despite
our opposing political beliefs
but there are contentious issues just
yesterday sunday tsipras underscored his
view that the eu bailout program has
failed
it's an opinion most of europe doesn't
share but it would seem that
confrontation is inevitable what was
your impression after private talks with
him
i didn't have that impression our talks
were not amicable
and still we were able to find some
areas of compromise
i wasn't able to follow all of prime
minister cyprus's remarks before the
greek parliament sunday evening
but my feeling is that he's not
particularly interested in finding
agreement with the rest of europe at all
costs
but he has to realize that europe
consists of many democracies not just
greece alone
and it's up to him to produce points
that will lead to an accord
there's no way that all 27 or all 18
euro countries will move unilaterally in
athens direction
there has to be
in other words greece would be forced
out of the eurozone if it refuses to
obey the rules of membership
that scenario doesn't appear on my radar
screen in my three years as eurogroup
boss i did my best to assure that greece
would not leave the euro nor would it be
forced out of the eurozone
nor would it jeopardize its eurozone
membership on purpose
now that the situation is improving
there's no need to look at worst case
scenarios
prime minister tsipras feels the same
way
so we will work together to assure that
greece remains part of the eurozone
of course it's critical that we abide by
the terms of the greek bailout
this is about interdependence
one for all and all for one
what can you
on november 27 2012 the eurogroup
released a final protocol it stipulates
in black and white which further steps
the participating countries could take
if greece fulfilled certain obligations
i stand by that protocol because there's
no better plan it's a solid plan because
i chaired the meeting on november 27
2012 and i personally formulated the
conclusions
so i'm standing by it
is germany too fixated on keeping to the
exact terms of the stability package it
has caused considerable backlash within
the eu
no europe needs this virtuous triad
first budgetary responsibility adherence
to the stability criteria
second structural reforms that are
absolutely necessary
and third programs that promote economic
and job growth
europe simply must deal with its
investment problem the reticence to
invest private capital
it's not germany's fault for
concentrating on fiscal responsibility
others can't be faulted for pursuing
responsible spending and structural
reforms along with the vital third point
creating jobs and growing the economy
one of your most ambitious projects is
the investment package
just a reminder to our viewers it has a
315 billion euro price tag
21 billion of that has already been
earmarked
and you want a ratio of 1 to 15 in terms
of public funds and private capital
how do you intend to convince investors
to bet on europe
there's more than enough capital
available in europe
the problem is all of those funds are
being invested where they don't belong
they should be put to work to kick-start
growth
the goal of this investment package is
to avoid new debt and increasing
deficits
we want to rely as little as possible on
eu revenue
but to use those funds as leverage for
financial instruments that will produce
stronger and more intense investment in
europe
the package encompasses research energy
production digital europe a european
energy union
it's about increasing europe's economic
potential in the medium term
that will also create more jobs
throughout europe
are you concerned that the variety of
projects will become a political
football that the 28 member countries
will be fighting to get the biggest
piece of
the allocations won't be made by the
european commission rather the european
investment bank
i consciously made this decision to keep
the project from becoming mired in
bureaucratic wrangling that often
produces bad choices
individual governments or parliaments
won't be able to put pressure on the
commission
the projects must be the kind that
wouldn't be undertaken without the
investment package
they must also be projects that present
a real potential for economic growth and
job creation
speaking of individual countries looking
at the ukraine crisis diplomatic efforts
are being made by individual nations
german chancellor merkel french
president hollande where is eu foreign
policy chief federica mogherini
knew full well why they did so and what
they were trying to accomplish
would it help if you played a bigger
role possibly as mediator
negotiating peace is much more important
as commission president is there
something you can offer russia that
might defuse the situation perhaps a
customs union
i'm sure you've noted that talks are
underway between germany france the eu
russia and ukraine
it makes no sense to comment on these
negotiations from the sidelines
we'll allow the negotiators to do their
job and keep our opinions to ourselves
you've changed sides so to speak for the
past 20 years you've held positions on
the european council and now you're eu
commissioned president do you feel you
have more power now that you can exert
more influences
questions like that leave me cold as
luxembourg prime minister and eurogroup
boss i did everything in my power to
manage the economic crisis
as commission president i can take
certain steps to promote economic growth
and job creation
i'm well acquainted with the member
nations and with the workings of the
commission
i have a broad view that keeps me on a
solid course
i did enjoy our interview